let's go to your voicemails two one nine
two david p we talked about this keurig
that we got as a gift from matt we
talked about maybe destroying it or
maybe giving it to pat or whatever and
the eggman called in and is completely
uh definitive in his opposition to the
destruction of the keurig take a listen
to this dave you should give the kurds
machines a pat and never mention it
again maxing it would be the stupidest
thing you could do it's it's the r-word
of things to do it's a perfectly
functioning working coffee machine is it
going to destroy and there's going to go
into a landfill and be trance that's the
exact opposite what us liberals do we
reduce reuse and recycle and if it can
be reused you reuse it it's a smart
thing to do United stupid is why would
you want to cement it you know those
people god yes
you complain about the curve because it
takes two cups of water to freeze
quickly boil one cup it wastes a little
bit a little bit but you lose water any
with anything also and feel like how it
tastes
so what other people do Pat does his
taste buds are more burnt off than yours
yeah it's very stupid to destroy that
big fellow brother
okay Shalom Eggman yep I like how he
calls it the Keurig as opposed to Keurig
listen number one in terms of throwing
it in a landfill isn't plastic
recyclable these days I mean the Keurig
is made of plastic so it might be
recyclable but you actually I gave Pat
the opportunity to test it I'll say do
we do we want to have this as the office
coffee machine for Pat I wouldn't go
near it trust me and it doesn't seem to
actually work correctly as well as the
audience knows I use the reusable pods
yeah as not to waste too much plastic
sure and this is the Keurig 2.0 sure and
it doesn't work with reusable pods nor
does it work with any of the off-brand
pon pods so I'm just done with it I'm
done with Keurig altogether so I don't
get it what would you you'd have to buy
only the curent by the Keurig pods which
I'm not willing to do how much do those
cost compared to like the other
alternative I don't know I'm just so
upset with this I nearly smashed it out
in the kitchen there
I had actually brought it out to the
the shared kitchen and the next thing
within about 90 seconds I'd say I heard
a banging and then a really loud
conversation that seemed agitated
between Pat and another F in the
building had to be restrained and I knew
that if I was going to destroy it I
probably should wait to do it on camera
yeah right right in some ways it's too
late yeah so anyway it's in Pat's car
now but no I'm kidding it's it's still
here but I guess people don't like the
destruction idea great bonus show today
get access to the bonus show by going to
david pakman.com slash membership get
the free calendar with your membership
at david pakman.com slash calendar 18
and patreon is good again they've
rescinded their fee increase and you can
go to patreon.com/scishow and also
access the bonus show with a $5 a month
pledge